confiné par les forces de l'ordre dans
leur établissement les lycéens de saint
Thomas d'Aquin retrouvent enfin leur
proche
certains sont en larmes tous parents et
enfants sont traumatisés tu l'as vu agir
et là tu es tu as su que c'était très
grave au moment où ça s'est passé
[Musique]
à la prof d'espagnol sur sa poitrine
évidemment je ne viendrai pas sur le
terrain de l'enquête judiciaire qui
vient de s'ouvrir simplement vous dire
tout le soutien que nous portons la
communauté éducative dans son ensemble
selon des témoignages le suspect âgé de
16 ans aurait dit avoir entendu des voix
et se sentir possédé en tout environ 90
élèves sont pris en charge depuis ce
matin par une cellule psychologique de
cette fabrique du crétin on arrive
maintenant à la fabrique de l'assassin
dans le fond et cela pose bien sûr le
problème de l'éducation cela pose de
problème également de la vigilance de la
famille elle-même et je le mets en
perspective avec le le la personnalité
si fade aujourd'hui du ministre de
l'éducation mais c'est pas pendent vous
pestez pendant que vous l'écoutez
Emmanuel Macron mais c'est parce que
c'est tellement méprisant et méconnaître
la réalité du monde du travail c'est
plus un président de la République c'est
un méprisant de la République fait
désormais 32 jours sans plus la France a
enregistrée la plus longue sécheresse
mithologique depuis le début des mesures
en 1959 les précipitations attendues
aujourd'hui et demain ne devrait pas
combler ce déficit plus géométrique de
l'ordre de 50% des samedis le prix sur
les autoroutes chez Total énergie du
support et diesel sera au maximum à 1,99
€ dans toutes les associations hors
autoroute ça sera le 1er mars et on va
pas faire ça pour deux mois pour trois
mois on le fait pour toute l'année je
vais revenir sur monsieur pouyanais et
les scandales oui c'est le cartel des
financiers le cartel du CAC 40 ce cartel
là il se comporte quasi avec des
pratiques mafieuses c'est à la une du
quotidien local la fermeture de mécano
un coup dur pour la ville de Calais et
pour ses habitants ah bah oui ça fait
bizarre
EDF se retrouve à racheté à 300 euros
d'électricité qu'il a vendu 42 46 euros
à total c'est entre 6 à 8 milliards
d'euros que Total a reçu de EDF rien que
par cette manipulation Charlie et la
chocolaterie le bon gros géant ou encore
Mathilda intemporel ces histoires de
Roald Dahl ont fait le tour du monde et
viennent d'être modifié avec l'accord de
ses ayants droits afin selon eux que les
enfants d'aujourd'hui continuent de les
apprécier depuis son rachat par le
groupe canadien Speedmaster il y a 10
ans elle cumulent près de 10 millions
d'euros de dettes et face à la flambée
des coûts des matières premières et de
l'énergie le groupe a décidé de jeter
l'éponge il était gras avant il est
devenu maigre comme une allumette dans
la nouvelle version le mot gras il se
passa a été supprimé autre exemple avec
cet extrait du bon gros géant quelque
chose de tout noir de tout noir et de
tout grand de tout noir de tout grand et
de tout Mince ici le mot noir sera
remplacé par sombre
les salariés doivent reprendre la
production cet après-midi mécano Calais
fermera définitivement ses portes en
octobre prochain une centaine de
passages a été modifiée provoquant un
tollé au pays de l'auteur le Royaume-Uni
le Premier ministre allant jusqu'à
condamner ses modifications l'écrivain
Salman rushdy dénonce une censure
absurde il y a un député qui a vu son
collègue aidé par des huissiers parti
vomir pour l'autre c'est la présidente
de séance qui une fois le dîner je cite
donc le Parisien une fois le dîner passé
n'avait plus toutes ces idées en place
certains députés étaient
ivrent vous avez constaté ça mécano
ferme mais c'est joué continueront
d'exister et seront désormais importés
d'Asie ou d'Amérique du Sud sincèrement
non enfin je je vais pas mentir je
sincèrement non voilà
pas du tout